in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week professor Muller
what's going wrong in tomato's disease
well if that's a autoimmune disease ie
the body produces antibodies against the
thyroid that leads to an inflammation
and this inflammation leads to a
hyperactive thyroid in the beginning but
then it completely destroys the thyroid
and you end up with very low thyroid
function so depending on the thyroid
function you've got different symptoms
so what are the symptoms about with the
hyperactive thyroid for example well
with a hyperactive thyroid you have too
much thyroid hormone and that regulates
the whole match of metabolism of the
body so you are overactive you always
feel hot
you can't sleep you're very nervous so
you have all the symptoms of
hyperactivity and then the lower
activity or the under and the long run
you develop a very low thyroid hormone
state and that leads to a very depressed
metabolism ie you are slow you're tired
you want to sleep you always feel cool
your hair is getting out so you feel
depressed and you can you can
treat this by giving thyroid hormone so
given the normal hormones you against
the thyroid gland usually produces
that's right and what are the treatment
options for the high functioning it's
very well if you have an overactive
thyroid you give drugs to block the side
of metabolism in order to bring the
thyroid hormone level down to the normal
and these drugs are toxic but they help
you very much to do the activity but
it's giving this medication actually a
cure for the disease or you have to do
anything else to cure me say Hashimoto
in Hashimoto's there is no different
therapy you don't have to do anything
else but regulating the thyroid
metabolism so you either have to block
the metabolism all you have to
substitute apart from that you don't
have to do anything and normally you
don't have to do an operation and before
you bring the patient into the operation
room and there's another alternative
which is called radioactive iodine
therapy what's this this is a very good
and elegant therapy for hyper
functioning yes I write it you give a
capsule with radioactive iodine-131
iodine and this iodine gets only taken
by the thyroid cells so the overall
radiation for the body is very very low
and we thyroid cells take this iodine
and destroy themselves so this is a very
good and elegant therapy but it works
only in a hyper functioning ferrand and
then how does it actually work so he
just prescribed the medication and the
patient takes it at home or is there
something so now you go to a special
ward in Germany you have to go to a ward
that is closed you can't even leave it
in many other countries you can just go
home after that and you get a very
definite dose of this radioactive iodine
and then
you can also do a scintigraphy so you
can scan the thyroid using this
radioactive radiation and you can see
whether it works or not and when do you
actually have to operate well the main
reason to operate is a suspicion of
cancer so if you think that there is a
malignant not you learn as I Road then
you usually would have to operate other
indications are if the thyroid is very
very large a goiter that is large and
you have a compression of the trachea or
you have problems to swallow so in very
large tournaments you would perform an
operation and of course also in the
hyper functioning thyroids where the
rider active radioactive iodine therapy
does not work many patients need to be
operated on the thyroid gland but many
of my patients are afraid if I tell them
they have to go to the surgeon or
dangerous is surgery on thyroid gland
well all operations have risks and
therefore it is very important to
balance the indication very well with
the rhesus and oh of course we're always
trying not to operate but if it comes to
an operation we can perform these
operations very safely today the typical
risks of the operation can usually be
avoided and the general risk of any
complication is well below 1% so the
normal risk for operation is major
bleeding or infection but there is some
special risk in the third one special
risk of federal operations is very
current nerve this is a nerve that is
important for your speech for the vocal
cords and this nerve unfortunately is
directly next to the thyroid and it is
very important to
save this nerve and if you damage the
nerve the patient gets horse oh yeah you
have some degree of coarseness if you
have only a damage on one side usually
this will recover but you must never
have the damaged medical science so how
do you protect the nerve G of the
surgery today we have what we call nerve
monitoring so we can do with the
operation not only visually define the
nerve
I always operate with magnifying glasses
and I can see the nerve but this nerve
monitor all also is a function control
so I can stimulate the nerve
continuously where during the operation
and see that the nerve is attacked and
that is a very great help when I find my
in my office some lumps and the thyroid
gland of my patients the patient's
usually afraid that lumps are cancer so
what do you have just tell them is it
always cancer well most nodules in the
thyroid are benign so and if they are
small there is no need for an operation
and in fact there's no need for a worry
we only operate on nodules that have
simple symptoms of cancer that are
suspicious of cancer and perhaps only 3
to 5 percent of the nodules really a
thyroid cancer and if you want to treat
a benign not you can you can you affect
it with some dietary advice well the
reason for the goiter and for this
nodules is usually and
and efficiency that develops very often
in the childhood and if as an adult you
take an iodine or thyroid hormone then
this therapy unfortunately is very
ineffective so in fact for coid there is
no good medical therapy and coming to
iodine therapy we've got a lot of viewer
questions one was from vietnam lady tom
who i'm for vietnam ask if you can
actually take too much iodine
well iodine is only taken up by the
thyroid and you lose it via the urine so
if you take too much iodine and your
thyroid is healthy and normal and there
is no problem that can be a problem if
you have an autonomy decide oh it's a
hyper function a hyper activity of the
thyroid then you might run into problems
but as a healthy normal subject with a
normal thyroid you can check as many
iodine everyone got another viewer
question from ghana luma lewis as
something about medication she's on am
tired medication for some weeks and now
she's got some side effect you said
she's tired and she's freezing and joins
to know how they're going with the side
effects well probably she does not take
enough thyroid hormone it sounds a
little bit more like a low thyroid
hormone level so what you should do is
you should see her doctor and he
would have to take blood and measure the
thyroid hormone level and see whether
she needs more probably she should take
them take a little bit more serisone
great advice thank you
first I'm gonna for being of this show